mm-hmm
that we're live
Marcus what's up bud
first one
grass toucher Daniel quach what's up
remember in the chat Jake what's up
Daniel and Ethan chunky
Mason Alvin Jeff Aquino what's up man
Cupid time random nugget
Ashton Mitchell Damien
idiot he was a fan yeah what's going on
are you moving kind of fast for me now
how is everyone doing
She-Hulk finale I um
I know what happens in the finale
and I don't
I don't know
how fans exactly are I don't know how
they're going to react to it
I don't know how you all are going to
perceive this finale it's quite
interesting it's very different very
very different
expect a lot of
fourth wall
fifth wall sixth ball breaking a lot a
lot of stuff
oh it's kind of dark
that's okay let's set the mood
just pull up
well Elgato they always spawn to the
stream they're awesome all I gotta do is
boom easy thank you to Elgato for the
awesome equipment sponsoring the stream
and some people have actually noticed
that my mic sounds a little bit better
recently it's because I use this new
Elgato microphone it's really awesome
I use it for my videos not using it
right now using the headset Jeff
thank you for Super Chat already excited
we're glad to be over uh
I'm not glad that it's over
um it didn't go the way I thought it was
gonna go
the finale could be make or break it
really could be um
hi Sue I see you
I know you're really excited I know
you've loved the series too I I okay
there's a little bit more people in chat
now uh Jeff thank you again for that
Super Chat I'll kind of address this
right now your your question right now
Mr Anderson in the chat what's up to the
best mod out there um
this finale is going to be just like way
different
and I think and I haven't seen it I've
heard
uh yes Kyrie is on the couch
Sue
that's Kyrie and rocket
was right here I have no idea where she
went
that's probably one to get some food or
something
um
hello everyone welcome welcome welcome
so I'm not gonna spoil the finale
obviously but I um
I know what happens pretty much
everything except for maybe a few things
because I I heard they made some changes
I heard today they made some changes
let me let me rephrase that today I
heard that they made some changes I
don't know when they made those changes
I doubt they made them today but today I
heard they made some changes and um
this is going to be way different than
anything we've seen
and it really can be hit or miss it
honestly is it's gonna be hit or miss
um
I can't say anything I'm not gonna spoil
it
um
so uh all I can say is I'm anxious for
this one
be really cool from a few things I heard
are gonna be really cool I think
I have to see it visually
I'm not gonna I'm not really gonna give
any more
information
I don't want to give that much more
information
hold on let me adjust the lights again I
still feel like it's kind of dark
which one is this that's better right
oh wait hold on
there we go I was missing a light it's
missing my ring light
let me bring this down
wait yeah bring this down set the vibe a
little bit more
there we go
yes chunky I see you
I'm glad they pushed him back too I'm
glad Marvel has pushed back
so much stuff
I would rather it get pushed back
than it'd be released and be bad you
know I think
I think most people can agree there
yeah I haven't seen it for those asking
I haven't seen it I just heard from
people who have seen it
um I think people I think most people
Realize by now I work with Disney uh
with them not for them I want to like
distinguish that I obviously like go to
the premiers and stuff so I can promote
their stuff right they don't pay me I've
never been paid by Disney despite what
some people would say
um
but you know I I talk to people so I've
heard things
um and I'm actually friends with
like all the leakers like anybody out
there that
I'm not gonna drop names but pretty much
a good majority of the leakers out there
I I talk to I talked to a few today
actually or a couple today I talked to
two of them today actually just to kind
of confirm what I heard and they did and
I'm like
okay
I'm like uh
I'm really anxious to see this finale
and I really
want to see them pull it off
I'm not giving any spoilers for it
um
sometimes I get
info from the inside like black panther
too I uh and this is I'm being like dead
serious I have no idea
about like Doctor Doom like those rumors
like that I have I have zero idea
the Illuminati I I had heard rumors but
I wasn't confirmed if it's something
like really really big I won't hear
anything from anyone at Disney ever like
they won't give it away they won't give
it away it's usually like an Insider
that has to tell me but like sometimes
like people at Disney they're like oh
this is the big one I'm like oh
okay
so
the Los Angeles Lakers that's funny uh
yeah I I don't
I don't know how
so overall the show
I'm I talked about this
two weeks ago I don't think I I don't
think it was after the last episode I
think it was two weeks ago
I think it was marketed wrong
I really do
um
I think if it was if it was marketed
differently
a lot of people would have liked it a
lot more
and if you
are enjoying the show awesome
if you didn't like it I can understand
I totally could understand
I don't know I rank it yet the finale
really like
it's it's big right so somebody said
this the other day
and they kind of said that Marvel's been
kind of missing with the finales
and I'm trying to think
back like yeah the Miss Marvel finale
didn't do it for me it really didn't
it was like
the apps it was like there was no
villain right
it was like Camron
but he wasn't really a villain you know
so
I don't know it didn't do it for me I
felt like they they rushed a lot of the
finale and I'm I'm worried that it's
gonna happen in this finale
um
I feel like She-Hulk had a lot of Filler
episodes
and that concerns me with the finale
but there were good episodes that I
really enjoyed
and there were some that I just really
didn't like but going back to the finale
thing yeah a lot of people were like
yeah they didn't like the moon night
finale like it was okay like I feel like
just what we're missing is something
that's like
hello hello my headset died let me plug
it in
sorry about that
hello yeah you guys seen something
um
like let's see if we go through
Marvel here
actually wait time out
time out what did everybody think of
werewolf by night
I want to know Rockets here I want to
know what people thought of werewolf By
Night rocket come here everyone wants to
see you hey
ma'am what you doing come here
everyone's waiting on you
oh you little silly kitty no we're not
gonna get in the cat tree right now
what are you doing
say hi
say hi to people
you're on camera say hi
what are you doing
what you doing you say hi
you said woof woof
there you go
that's rocket
okay it was dope ten by ten loved it
loved it loved it yeah see
Mr Anderson thousand out of ten yeah we
talked about that
yeah everybody is
I I love seeing everybody
talk about
how good
werewolf by night is wow
that's awesome
what's up Brandon yo yo yo
yo the muck thanks for the Catalyst
thank you for that super chat I am that
was rocket Kyrie is right
there sleeping
she so it's funny does she she doesn't
it's a wine yeah I guess I guess she
does wine Sue but she always make that
noise like no matter what like she she
could be purring be like perfectly happy
like like a perfect example when I got
home tonight from a hockey game I walked
in my room and she went like that high
really high pitched yeah she's just
looking at me right now because she's
like what are you doing I make that
noise
yeah she just she always has that high
pitch you know
she always has Joey says
uh we have 13 minutes the episode comes
up
so it is not out yet let's pull it up
though
I have
Google Chrome that's what it's called
pulled up and yep it's still showing
let's go ahead and test that though just
to make sure we're all set up
I wonder
I wonder what
I wonder what this one's going to be
called cool cool
uh what hockey game I play hockey
and since I played an adult league we
play very late at night actually
sometimes we play like I've had games at
11 30 at night and I get home at like 1
30. it's it's rough
uh um
it's my opinion on the short run time
yeah I'm concerned uh Eve Evie EV
probably butcher that I'm sorry EV
um
I'm concerned for the short run time I
really am
um
I just like I don't understand excuse me
I have had a little bit of an issue with
the writing on some of these Disney Plus
shows like I I have just to be honest
like
I didn't particularly enjoy the writing
of Miss Marvel I thought a lot of the
stuff I saw was really cool and I
enjoyed the series overall but the
writing really threw me off
and I even talked to some other people
who I know
who were like write Scripts
write books write movies and I asked
them what they thought and they're like
yeah I didn't like the writing so
I that's kind of been a concern of me
lately and I think it just comes with a
diverse content from Marvel right now
because we have so much
but some could be better so I'm
concerned that we get these Filler
episodes
and I think She-Hulk gave us a lot of
Filler episodes I really do in my honest
opinion
um and I wish
that didn't happen I wish we progressed
a lot more like it's the final episode
and
the True Villain hasn't been revealed
which is really weird
it's just really weird like yeah we know
it's intelligencia but
but like who's the main villain right
you know so
so
yes Lily that's what I'm talking about
like they were there were Filler
episodes and I was and I'm like like
really with the writing like
we couldn't
like we couldn't think of something
better but hey a lot of some people are
enjoying that you know
some people are enjoying that
um
so I will say uh now I'm not I don't I'm
not gonna spoil anything I don't wanna I
don't want to give anything away we can
talk about it after we can talk about it
after
hey Jeff likes K-pop
um I watch shows in Korean
I think that's what she was referring to
and sometimes like when I play Disney
plus it's still in Korean
we are in English there you go
I am ready Nikki the great what is up we
have nine minutes left
hello
to Finland
hello Finn Mike hello hello
uh uh Daniel question like K-pop too uh
for the K-pop fans
uh let me do something
I haven't like announced this at all
because I've been kind of just keeping
it a secret but I do have a K-pop
Channel come on my typing right now is
just atrocious
I do have a K-pop Channel I'll put it in
the chat
uh uh I do it for fun
not not for like money or anything which
is why I haven't really told anybody
about it but here it is if you go follow
it go follow it John John what is up
thank you for that Super Chat really
appreciate that hopefully this oh wait
hold on I'm losing it hopefully the
street side of the MCU we will get to
see
Kung Fu take on super soldier like
bucking John Walker who would win
have the ring 10 Rings because he would
win
um
I I also feel like his fighting style
like I feel like John Walker and Bucky
are more like
Brute Force
and chunky is more technique right
plus he did even without the Rings kind
of learned a little bit of the Mystic
side of Tallow like so maybe he still
kind of has you know that little bit of
Mystic ability when he fights so
I would say
uh hero thank you so much um hold on I
saw a question
I think Mr Anderson deleted it because I
saw you posted a few times but who would
win between Superman and homelander and
and all of those uh I don't remember the
other one that you put
Superman
I feel like homelander is very
unpredictable which could give him an
edge but
could also be a weakness
yeah Lily I think the same thing I I
think without the Rings shanxi would
still have the upper hand
but I don't know Bucky's vibranium arm
what's going on Leon
Oklahoma
Denzel Washington is blue Marvel uh I've
heard a rumor
this is like straight up rumor I have no
idea how true this is so don't take it
as like a leak or anything like that but
you could possibly be playing
Dracula and blade
straight up rumor no idea the validity
of that no idea
you think Megan the stallion is going to
become uh Red She-Hulk I think we've
seen the last of Megan the Stalin unless
there's like a party for She-Hulk at the
end or something like that and she shows
up or something
uh boy I go for blue Marvel wouldn't be
bad he's he's already done you know
stuff with Disney
well I watched Black Adam in in theater
Stark absolutely I I'm so excited for
that movie and I don't even care like
I know some people are like oh it's
going to be a mid movie but I feel like
to me it's just one of those movies
that's like I'm gonna go in not
expecting like a cinematic Masterpiece
and enjoy myself very much and have a
really fun time and I love the Rock and
I think I think the Rock's gonna crush
it as Black Adam and I mean Pierce brosn
as as Dr Fate I mean geez hey that's so
cool to me 007 that was my 007 growing
up so it's like
that's really cool
uh five minutes people what was that
noise
did anybody hear that noise or is it
just like in my headset for something
maybe I have like another window open or
something like that
what is happening
I think that was like an ad that went
off on like a website or something that
was so weird sorry I heard this really
weird noise
um Captain Graham so I think Harrison
Ford
is fit to be the new Red Hulk he is
rather old but he did just film Indiana
Jones five so
I think he's fit hey Celestial another
member in the chat what's going on
welcome welcome welcome
Bradley Jones dooman what kind of
forever post credit scene I talked about
that earlier um I have no idea I haven't
heard anything
about it besides like the the rumors
that everybody else has heard so
I don't know unfortunately I would hope
so it it just makes sense the whole
do-more storyline
I mean
yeah what's up Alex Guzman love back
uh
uh see some people talking about Black
Panther kind of forever
I think it I think it would just make
sense to put him
I don't think I I don't think they'll do
like a big reveal I think they might
just mention his name maybe like Victor
or you know Von Doom or something like
Doom
um
well they show him in the post-credit
scene oh I mean it'd be a hell of a
post-credits scene and we know the
Fantastic Four are coming right so it's
like
you know
we'll see
I feel like Pennywise we didn't get a
lot of the lawyer stuff
you know
like yeah we got some of it but they
they advertise it as like a lost show
and I didn't
really
get a lot of that like I feel like we
did in the first few episodes but it
kind of fell off a little bit
I think we're gonna get it a little bit
more in this last episode
uh Jimmy choose I do think Spider-Man 4
is going to be a team up with Daredevil
I hope
I
hope
um according to thecosmiccircus.com
their report
was it yesterday
um yeah he's going to be kind of
cleaning up some stuff from uh from
Daredevil so we can see could double
three be
going on in the MCU uh Cash Money it is
going to be in the MCU 100 percent
100 percent
oh two minutes
two isn't isn't this a sitcom more than
everything else yes rainbow F but they
didn't Market it that way
they marketed a show
with a lot of action and a lot of Hulk
smashing and I'm not talking about
Daredevil
um
and that's kind of my issue with it
plot twist Nikki is the big bad you know
I've seen some people say that I don't
think that's the case I think she's good
I will say
I
I wasn't too happy with the fourth wall
breaking in this I felt like it could
have been better I I felt like sometimes
it was funny
but I feel like it missed a lot for me
all right
um
one minute
uh Marlon no I'm so sorry I do not know
how to fix that maybe just keep
refreshing
get ready people because it's about to
start in one minute I will show some of
it on screen
as you can see here I will be showing
some of it
I think people are going to be
happy and shocked by this finale
do you think that will be miles
Spider-Man 4 the mouse episode one uh
Berkus Thompson welcome welcome another
member and I
I don't know they might set him up all
right I think it's out
Leon High accident your message about my
comics
huh
I don't really know what you mean by
that I'm sorry can you re-
oh elaborate in the chat please all
right it's out we are going to start
this right now I'm going to start in a
five four three two one
it's starting
Leon just go ahead and type in chat
you'll have to Super Chat I'll look I'll
look for your uh I'll look for your chat
because I'm not sure what you mean by
that
I don't remember messaging about a uh
comment
foreign
let me do this
oh here we go
oh my gosh it's all true
it's all true
everything I heard was true oh gosh
kind of like werewolf by night right now
it's it's like the old for it's like the
Lou Ferrigno Hulk I love it
let me do that oh I did not mean to do
that hold on
come on there we go
look at this
this is so old school
it's just like Lou frig knows Hulk
The Savage She-Hulk she's in the prison
like a meal was in
even wearing the same clothes oh it's
her team
there's a barcode on her chest
oh she's in the she's in the the prison
[Laughter]
considering I was calling the freaking
Hulk
hmm so everyone just sees her as the out
of control Hulk and it's going back to
what Bruce Banner said once people sees
you as a monster you know
everything I heard about this episode is
true by the way look she has to wear
an ankle monitor that keeps it from
turning into the Hulk
She-Hulk sorry into She-Hulk
and then her parents are there picking
her up uh hold on y'all I need to switch
screens
her dad because people could have prison
every day
okay here we go so now I can
do this
she got fired from her job
and Nikki is going to continue to work
there because
she makes money and everybody's talking
about her on the news now of course
and now she
yeah people are out yep people are
outside of her house and news reporters
and everything it's just like her cousin
said in the first episode
she's gonna have to move back into her
parents house yep
she lost her job because of the She-Hulk
incident last episode and now she yep
no and all the reporters are after her
her dad sprays them with the hose get
off my lawn
her parents are actually pretty funny
now she's moved back home
is that it
this is the scene that we saw today
what am I doing no stop it please I
gotta turn this off or it's gonna be
copyrighted nope oh my gosh
this is
by any in all means Nikki's not the
villain
gosh her mom is like freaking cooking up
a
making everything for Nikki
oh it's oh gosh
foreign
video of gin Walters
that's funny
oh gosh this douche Dennis Bukowski
oh my gosh he's saying they dated
oh that's sad
she can't turn into her whole her her
her her mom asked if she could move
something for her and she says no
because she has the ankle bracelet that
keeps her well it doesn't keep it from
turning into She-Hulk but alerts people
yes it's what we want
that
that's kind of funny
smug Hulk
not delivered because he's in space
he's on sakar
dang girl you texted a lot of people
so she's texting a meal now
gonna that wasn't delivered either
yeah J.R everything that you've heard is
true because I saw everything I heard I
saw a little bit of it posted online oh
gosh
so Nikki is now trying to
infiltrate Intelligentsia to try to
figure stuff out
how how how did people just start
replying so fast people don't even reply
of us when I post videos
bro
pug so she's calling her paper from pug
now
that's funny oh my gosh keep doing that
I'm sorry I meant to do this
look
guy from The Wrecking Crew
and Doug are you not going to ask him
I'm a little confused
oh gosh that is a small car
I love pug he is a great Nikki and pug
are two phenomenal characters in the
series I will say that
please don't make me do this
oh he's refer to women as females
she should be wearing she should be
wearing or he should be wearing two
earbuds
oh look at all the Bros
lady Thor she just sucks it's all the
Bros
I would have the same criticisms if she
was a man
come on pug Pug's too good of a guy
foreign
oh look who it is
[ __ ]
Todd fell
oh there it is good old Todd
this guy rules
Andy's hot okay
is this why Todd hates the Hulk because
he's gay is that the like big twist of
it
super power should go to the best person
suited for the job geez
you think she boned Holloway
it pisses me off
laughs
I created Intelligentsia
I'm Hulk King boom there it is easy
this is what we've been talking about
people this is what we've been talking
about
I don't know if pug can't improvise
Nikki
yep she gets it the guy can't Improv
for real action
oh do you see the meditation thing
behind him
that's totally in a meal thing
see are you not going to ask him about
the whole trying to get your blood thing
again I get a really culty vibe from
these like suits that they're wearing
oh my gosh the events at the lodge Lodge
I think some of you knew that who have
read some stuff online today
for abomination
look who it is
look who's here abomination
foreign
that
yeah Emil he's going to be totally he's
gonna be totally innocent
a meal
uh-oh uh oh
oh
I don't care
oh and there's Nikki
oh now she knows Todd is Hulk King
[Laughter]
still your blood
oh here it comes
he's gonna turn into a Hulk
yep there it is
I had to earn super powers and there it
is he injected himself with her blood
oh
here we go
this can't
oh
come at me bro oh look who it is
this isn't messy enough
and look Abomination has saved her
he's not actually bad and who's here
whoa Abomination is so much bigger than
the Hulk
all right and this is where it's gonna
get this is get yep here we go and it's
getting weird now wait for it
this menu is not gonna stop me I'm gonna
break through it
and There She Goes breaking out of it
this is the part I was kind of talking
about this is like a make or break part
it could be really good or it could be
incredibly bad we will see now look
where she's at in the suit
she's at Marvel Studios
at Marvel Studios
on the lot
yep
yep you can see all the Disney stuff in
the background yep
that's the She-Hulk building
she's walking in
and here are the writers for She-Hulk
there's got to be so many Easter eggs in
that right there
episode 107.
and she's talking about how stupid the
finale is
um
this is a story that Kevin wants you all
ready for this it's not what you think
but
I want to talk to Kevin
they all laugh
no one talks to Kevin
you'll never get close to him
oh
so here she goes in the Marvel Studios
look there's a logo in the back and
walking into
his office
let me have you sign our NDA blah blah
blah blah
it's kind of cool to see the Iron Man
suits behind her I've got She-Hulk here
for Kevin
and everyone has to sign the NDA
and now Marvel security is on top of her
and
she's beating up Marvel security
are you all ready for Kevin
look at that
are you ready for
Kevin
oh it's not even his voice I heard it
was his voice
knowledge enhanced visual energy Nexus
foreign
so Kevin
is a computer is it AI
no
I'll leave that debate up to the
Internet
foreign
the Marvel Cinematic Universe she's
delivering her closing argument
suspiciously close to Super Soldier
serum
my sticks
the k-e-v-i-n
can we not do Todd gets Hulk powers
Bruce would be now
Bruce is supposed to
ah there it is confirmation of Hulk's
movie
ah
would not mind seeing Daredevil again
Thor daddy issue Tony Stark Loki daddy
same daddy same issue
foreign
to us
and sometimes I'm at Murdock
laughs
and now we're back
oh
going back down
babe
oh
third of all
I'm here to help missed it we're done
look at this guy
oh Tania trying to get some
oh look who's there what the family Mr
Matt Murdock
wait for it I think something's about to
happen
[Music]
oh my gosh
laughs
oh
good use of co-counsel
look look guys look
guess what
guess what guess what
been to Wayne's car
World War Hulk incoming
boom
you mean in the courtroom or superhero
both
and that is She Hulk but there is a
post-credit scene
and here's the post credit scene
and boom wongers
you took your time
your time you got sucked in another show
didn't you
we have Wi-Fi
and boom there you go
all right
let me change screens and stuff again
make sure this is right there we go
yep
all right well
[Laughter]
what did everyone think
of the finale
I'm going back to that really
questionable
GI of scar
look at that
and
Hope Solo movie confirmed
what does everybody think yes rate it
everyone's already rating it please rate
it right now down below
rate it rate this episode rate we're
gonna do two things we're gonna rate
this episode First Rate the finale
I don't know who the actor is I think it
it might just be all CGI
I don't know who that actor is
Jonathan he'd rather watch Dark World
sue you didn't like it
Sue at 2.5 out of 10.
dang
I thought you're gonna like it
do you not like it because Matt Murdock
showed back up and you know and you
didn't link them together
this is what I meant when when the light
when the live started today
and I didn't want to give anything away
obviously right but this is what I meant
when I was talking about like they're
gonna do something that's going to be
very weird and you're gonna love it or
hate it
I don't know
how
I feel
to be quite honest
um
foreign
I think it was interesting
it was I was a supporter all season long
but El finale oh DJ wave D I'm sorry
Jr I knew the entire time I was I was
told in advance
um
what was gonna happen
um and then I saw that leak online today
and I was like well this is exactly what
freaking happens in the freaking finale
I was like so people are gonna know oh
I did but I heard that
Kevin feige was actually going to voice
Kevin they they might have changed that
I did hear today people were saying that
they changed something I also heard that
they were going to be more hulks in the
finale
um I don't know if uh it was going to be
like a red Hulk or more people injecting
themselves with the serum uh uh
yeah
um I think they're I
think she-hulk's sticking around I don't
know if they're gonna do a season two
hmm
I'm getting
I'm I'm getting
there's a lot of mixed reactions huh
yeah I mean I don't know so
it was very meta right and that's like
the whole thing with the fourth wall
breaking
I'm trying to
I'm trying to decide how I feel about it
I'm trying to decide how I feel about
this look at the CGI
but you know it's the first time we're
seeing them
yeah I mean I guess it looks fine hello
Fang
I just so happened to look over into
your error 404 out of ten Jeff like cape
that's so funny
um
I think it was clever
I think they went for it I think it was
a Miss for me
I
there was there was like zero climax
for that finale to me I just
it
to me the show didn't really build that
well like I was never like oh what's
gonna happen I was more
unsatisfied that I hadn't been teased
more or like given teased yeah like
given a little bit right because they
didn't really give us anything
leading up to you know all of the like
intelligence is not even really a
villain it's just Todd and even and she
changed it you know all at the end to
where it's like it's just a guy who just
made a website that was just hate
comments it was a bunch of stupid Bros
right that's not really a villain
right like now she's going to see him
for defamation all that stuff like that
um
I could see that they just I could see
how they wanted to like be very
self-aware it's a very self-aware show
they wanted to be meta they wanted to
break the fourth wall and they like real
so I don't know for for whoever was in
the chat in the beginning when I said
like they're gonna break the fourth
fifth sixth seventh wall like they
really went for it right I mean she she
literally went into Marvel Studios
and I do I do I do like the banter about
how like oh nobody talks to Kevin like I
I would kill you before I let you get to
Kevin like that's funny
because of Kevin feige president of
Marvel's is the man right
um
the men are the villains I think if you
were a woman it would make more sense to
you fair point I'm not a woman you know
um
and I guess but it was still very
anticlimactic to me
and I I'm really trying to be just you
know neutral about this I'm trying to
look at it just as far as like
you know I go into every episode or
every show and every episode just kind
of like
try not to expect too much
um
I just I I think it was a little too
meta
to me
did I miss the Super Chat I'm sorry
a cage so was the scar thing in the in
Canon like I don't feel like I said yes
it was Canon
um
it's been reported
for several months now I don't know how
many maybe three four that Hulk's
getting a solo film it's gonna be I
would say Loosely based off of the world
war Hulk storyline because there's a lot
of stuff that
has not been set up for World War Hulk
there's no X-Men really there's no
Illuminati the Fantastic Four aren't
here yet
um unless
unless they're gonna do World War Hulk
after Secret Wars which probably not
because they just introduced scar his
son
so
yeah but uh
episode 8 was by far the best episode
and even if you took away Daredevil in
that episode and just had She-Hulk with
doing all the fighting herself it would
have been the best episode because
I don't know the writing was better
right and I actually found it funny I
found Leap Frog funny and her
interactions with him funny and her
interactions with Daredevil were great
um
luck Dragon Lair thank you for that
Super Chat appreciate it
um
I'm assuming World War Hulk
is going to dive into
the mother and
um
they're gonna probably do you know like
a flashback or something like that you
know like show what happened but also
keep in mind Bruce Banner had zero
control over the Hulk of that time and
remembered nothing when he came out of
Hulk form when Thor when Thor played the
video and Natasha woke him up
Banner was like asking about what
happened in Age of Ultron
so
now Brew slash Professor Hulk which is
you know the mind of Bruce is dealing
with those repercussions right so
I'm wondering if we're gonna see some of
you know the the scar storyline from the
comics where scar hates the Hulk and
Trace to kill him
um but then
he explains like dude that was the Hulk
I'm not the Hulk I'm Bruce I don't
remember anything yada yada
um
zcy9951
thank you for that Super Chat
I'm a woman and I really didn't like the
show to me it was super degrading to
both men and women worst representation
of both not in a fun way and nothing
valuable been added to the MCU
I respect your opinion
I am more inclined to agree with you
unfortunately than I am to disagree with
you because I wanted to like the show
She-Hulk is a great character
I just don't like how they went about
the show
that's not to say there weren't some
good moments in the show and I did enjoy
a lot of moments in the show but uh I
I don't like it
I gotta be honest right like I I have to
be honest I can't uh I can't try to act
like I like something when I didn't like
it too much
um
and as far as like the degrading thing
like to men and women I can't speak for
women obviously but like yeah there were
some things about guys but like guys
like that exist I know some like that
and I don't like them
um like those Bros at the end of this
finale like
I've seen those Bros and they're douches
and they suck
so I can get like the hits on those guys
right I mean I get the hits on those
guys totally
some some parts of the show were like
really hitting the nail on the head I
think like
I yeah
Kevin Galindo I've seen you uh talk a
few times I'm glad you love the show I
do like please like from the bottom of
my heart just because if I ever say I
don't like something
please do not let that affect your
opinion if you like it please I like
really I will never ever shame anybody
for liking something I don't like or
disliking something that I do like your
opinion is your own and let's all be
cool about that right like
if you like it great if you don't
that's just it's just an opinion every
you know I love throwing love and
thunder a lot of people didn't like
throwing love and thunder I have zero
shame I'm not changing my mind I love
that movie I've seen it like seven times
so yeah
yes AR Vlogs they did talk about how
long was in another show uh
uh
has he showed up and he hasn't showed up
another
[Music]
Series has he just just movies
just shanxi and just Doctor Strange too
right
uh no Lincoln case I see you no I do not
think the mother is Valkyrie no
uh
exactly Mr Anderson we're different
people we can have different opinions
and
be perfectly happy
with each other well I'm more happy for
you than me because I didn't
particularly enjoy it that much it's not
that I I don't hate the show by any
means
I'm not gonna watch it again
right like I've watched Loki a few times
I've watched One Division a few times
um and it was a no way home thank You
Tristan yes
uh well you thought one got sucked into
The Sopranos wouldn't it be funny if he
was I mean it's over but if he was
actually in that
I just
I just um
again if you like the finale great I'm
I'm really happy if you did I I really
am I to me I just there was never any
real tension
right it wasn't like
is
it's a lack of a main villain for me
that really
just kind of threw me off like
they teased like a general thing as a
villain but there's no like there was no
personification of it it was just this
entity out there and it was like
I mean it was intelligencia which in the
comics has crazy cool members like Modoc
and the leader and we thought it was
going to connect to Captain America 4
which it's still might but like I don't
know
Daniel
quach when do I think world war Hulk is
coming out uh
phase six
I want to say it's before Secret Wars I
just think it makes sense
um
but it might not be it might be after if
they are gonna do you know
the planet Hulk and World War Hulk
storyline
like with the Illuminati and tricking
him and sending him to the space and
everything that would mean we'd have to
have an Illuminati
so that that would probably be after in
all honesty because I don't think the
X-Men are really going to be that big of
a thing until phase seven it's my
previous cage thank you for another
Super Chat since the Hulk movie was
announced d23 when you think we can see
it Basics
um I definitely think it's a possibility
for phase six I think they should do it
in phase six but again it depends on
like
you know their original report did say
it was going to be based off of world
war Hulk
um if they're gonna like I said stick to
the comics they're gonna have to wait I
can't see them cramming in a lot of you
know things before Secret Wars
but maybe I mean who knows scar could be
the problem right I mean let me go back
to the scene here
he doesn't seem thrilled
he doesn't seem thrilled
but he's a Hulk
they're known for being angry
hey
all right I'm starting to pull hold on
what the heck's my chat
sorry to pull
dude
there it is
how about at chat tell us right there
go
go go go go do your thing
how old the scar uh I mean he looks
scenes
I mean he's a Hulk right so I don't I
don't know how they he was so here's the
crazy thing is he's born a Hulk right
he's not like
can you get an accident and get Hulk's
blood or you know gamma radiation
anything like that he was born a Hulk do
they age the same I mean I
20 early 20s late teens
right
absolutely no for you sue uh sorry the
chat's coming in pretty fast I don't
know what you're saying absolutely know
about
oh the She-Hulk finale
well start your voting
where are we at so far oh 56 percent no
I like this comment Spencer Richmond
this was t23 part two
hey look I I'm happy for everyone who
enjoyed the show enjoyed the finale I'm
so happy for you I really am
uh Dr J yes this originally was 10
episodes long they originally had 10
episodes and they cut it they cut one
for whatever reason maybe that was the
thing episode that we never got we'll
never no unless you know they come out
and tell us so
[Music]
I never like bothers me
I I see some people talking about like
CJ I was garbage like
let me get rid of this
DJI never bothers me too much because
I'm just like like I know it's not real
right so like bad CJ doesn't
take that away from me it's not like I'm
like looking I was like Oh I thought it
was real oh no the CGI is bad now I can
tell it's CJ I get how people are like
yo this sucks but
yeah I agree Sue it should have been six
episodes uh
yeah I
yeah
I
I didn't like it sorry
and it wasn't like a f if I had to rate
it right
but it's like borderline D plus C minus
to me
ha that's funny Nicholas Jarrett Eric
Boss reading the entire NDA yeah
there's a lot to break down in this uh
I'm going to do kind of an Indian
explained video talking about this
um
and then work on the breakdown tomorrow
it's very late for me right now so I I
can't do it all I and I played a hockey
game tonight at it started at 9 30. so
I'm very tired so I'm gonna get to work
on a
kind of like the post-credit video
Indian explained video we'll do that uh
tonight
but uh
uh Jonathan yes Cahoon that is
interesting how Hawkeye needed to be
longer this needed to be shorter I
um
hold on I saw
oh you said that Jonathan Cahoon just
got secret vision is next that can't be
butchered right I have heard
some people have seen test screenings of
Secret of aging and Invasion and it's
phenomenal
I hope this true
um yes I do think scar will come back
soon Iran
um
in the Hulk movie that's gonna happen
and they confirmed the Hulk movie she
said save it for the movie
there was definitely cool things about
this finale
and
if this wasn't the finale
I could have sat back and gone that's
cool
but the problem is it's the finale and
had zero climax to me this is just how I
feel right
if you liked it don't let my opinion
change for you to me it just didn't have
any climax I was just like
and like there was no
like that's like
there was nothing keeping me going for
the show right
like like I kind of think to myself like
if I wasn't such a huge MCU fan and of
course if this wasn't what I did full
time like as a job
I might have stopped watching five
episodes in
just to be honest
DJ wavy yeah his agent since the car
times to any age works also he like I
said he was born a Hulk as well so it's
like
does he age the same who knows
who knows
uh YouTube
what is happening here
why are you taking I don't want to go to
gaming YouTube why you do this
I've like never went to
yeah
uh Mr Anderson uh secret Invasion
doesn't have a official release date yet
I don't believe I just know it's 2023.
hold on
our own phase five
am I wrong when did the d23 say it was
coming out spring 2023 so not not an
official release date yet
excuse me uh
um
Ryan Shaw I had like the show but after
watching this episode on the fourth wall
break it just took me out of it I feel
like Marvel's moving farther and farther
away each project than what is was in
the Affinity song which we all loved
thank you for the Super Chat appreciate
it thank you for your input
um I could see how you would think that
I could see how a lot of people might
think that for sure
um
I think this always comes back to me
kind of saying the same thing
Marvel is producing way more content
than we're used to right before it used
to be like two three movies a year and
now it's like four movies a year
and like six Disney Plus shows and like
three specials and like it's so much
and does it part uh does a part of me
think
that they should slow down yes
yeah
um I I wonder like
I wonder if they have like a quota they
need to fill you know by Disney or
something but at the same time I'm like
a pirates are
at the same time I'm like no Kevin feige
caused the shots he does what he thinks
what he thinks is best and
I'm not
I'm not worried because I still think
Marvel Studios is going to bust out
great projects and there's going to be
the ones like the old ones that we love
during the infinity Saga but since they
are coming out with such
like higher
really higher volume of content since
they're putting it out there just by
like numbers there's gonna be
shows and movies that you don't like
that we don't like right
there's just every anybody
anyway right it's just not it's not
just because of the pure volume that
they're releasing shows in movies right
now just
it's just not you're not gonna love
everything that comes out but I but I in
the middle of that I think there are
going to be really great projects
that you love and they are Tailoring
certain projects to certain people they
are right
like I have like Wendy my my friend from
the movie couple if you're not
subscribed to them they're awesome
um I asked her
after like the sixth episode or
something because seven I was like
really losing interest in this in this
series I was like hey did you like this
episode and she's like yeah I'm it's
target audience I'm like
Fair
right
she's a woman she loves Marvel
I it makes sense right and you know we
had some people uh you know talking in
the chat who were women saying that they
didn't like it
and it's just really you know
everybody's different we don't have to
all be the same that's what makes the
world beautiful
but let's not like put each other down
for being different
you know I did personally enjoy the show
I
which is a bummer because I thought it
started out pretty strong
I really
I really thought it started out pretty
strong
um even like because some people are
like oh it started great with the Hulk
I'm like yeah but it's she-hulks
Siri she needs she does need to stand
alone
and I thought the second episode was
good third episode was okay but I like
the fourth one and then from there I was
just like
the eighth episode was the best yes
because of Daredevil but also because
the writing was just better
one thing that I'm
I don't I didn't like the writing for
this I didn't like the writing for Miss
Marvel I enjoyed Miss Marvel more than
this I enjoyed a lot of the visuals of
Miss Marvel I actually enjoyed the humor
more in Miss Marvel too
um the fourth wall breaking from
She-Hulk it didn't do it for me
sometimes it hit but a lot of times it
was a Miss for me
there you go Mr Anderson is that coming
out on Murphy's Multiverse question mark
because then we can just tell people to
look out for that Sue thank you for that
Super Chat
so we still don't know who she was
looking at I I think she was looking at
us because they didn't really they
didn't reveal anybody
so she she was looking at us breaking
the fourth wall which is still to me
like when I like I even after last live
stream I like stopped it I paused it I
went frame by frame I'm like it doesn't
even look like she's looking into the
camera that kind of threw me off because
I was like I actually think she is
looking into the camera
but it didn't look like it
so what did the poll close
where are we at with that pole
interesting
is literally 50 50 right now
did you like The Shield finale 50 yes 50
no
interesting
yeah interesting
uh scar is brown and gray not green no
he's green
that's green it's totally green he's
wearing a shirt you see you see that
he's wearing a shirt but he's totally
green
he has some of the markings on his arms
the Hulk did
um
that Hulk did I
I know she breaks the fourth wall in the
comics I oh I'm totally aware trust me
I've read the She-Hulk comics and I love
She-Hulk as a character uh they just
didn't hit for me
um I think I'm I might be excuse me I
just might be too used to Deadpool
that could honestly be a thing because
Deadpool is very much my humor
um
yeah
and again
uh if you love this show awesome please
continue to love it don't let anybody
else's opinion change that for you uh I
just have to
be honest
right I know a lot of people are always
like you say everything's the best I'm
like I I really don't
maybe maybe it seems that way and I
apologize but I do try to be honest uh
this this was a Miss for me hey the
movie Couples in the chat
hello
what is going on
Wendy and Dustin I just was talking
about you guys I don't know if you heard
it
Sue what is the one more reason that
makes this show bad for you
what is the one more reason I'm looking
for it what is the poll at
oh we're leaning more towards yes people
people like the finale 52 percent okay
all right all right
uh what is this today okay
I'm looking
a lot of people are kind of confused of
what they just watched it's kind of
funny
Is So Meta
it was So Meta uh movie couple
when the invested did you guys like
before you leave did you like
the finale
that that's true Mr Anderson it's very
different
very different play Styles but I felt
like
[Music]
that might change my mind a little bit
I'm open I'm hoping to change that makes
sense that makes sense but I feel like
ah to me like the biggest thing about
She-Hulk was the marketing like I feel
like they just marketed this show
the wrong way like I just really feel
that way I feel like if it was marketed
differently so many more people would
have enjoyed it
I really feel that way
it was meta City for sure that doesn't
say if you liked it or not be honest
I've I've been honest I've stated my
opinion in this live stream multiple
times I did not like the series I did
not like the finale it was too meta for
me and there was no
climax there wasn't really a reward
either
but do y'all like if you liked it by all
means
like Randy Burnside 900 watching get
likes over 450 shows oh thank you uh
show was awesome I'm so glad you liked
it
I really am
I I really am excited for everybody who
liked it Jonathan Cahoon what project
you're looking forward to the most 2023
let me take a look
let me just look at uh
wait what did I just do
phase five marble phase five let's take
a look
that's hard it really is hard there's
okay well luckily for me
hmm
uh oh man Ant-Man and quantumania
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 Loki I'm
really excited for those
I really am really excited for those
let's go back to
to scar he is very much green this is a
shirt that he is wearing
he's not Brown
uh I missed some comments hold on Sue
I'm still looking for yours I don't know
if you put it uh overall enjoy the
series there were episodes that we
enjoyed more than others
I like to I liked a good solid four
episodes I feel like the series should
have been six episodes so I think this
is the first time that I became so angry
for Marvel says oh wow did I miss
something
did I miss something else you said you
were gonna tell me another reason
you didn't like
the fact that she was looking at us with
that weird expression
yeah well there you go
uh
uh 53 of people are still saying they
they like the finale
that's pretty cool I'm glad because the
show really was getting a lot of hate
I'm glad uh
I'm glad people liked it
earlier
now we have to talk about the series as
a whole
yeah Mr Anderson right how they made
Moon night six episodes and this nine
will forever be confusing because I I I
really do feel I feel if they would have
got
if they got rid of
three episodes maybe four crammed cram
you know a lot of other stuff together
then
it would have been much better I also
feel like maybe they should have
released all of these at once
and maybe that would have been better
don't hold me to that I'm not sure how I
feel about that just a thought
I see some people talking about the
overall feeling
of the MCU where it's going like where's
the connectivity
uh feige said we'd see that soon and I
think
phase five is really when it's gonna
start coming together
I think phase six
or I'm sorry phase four
was very much
like experimenting testing the waters
you know
do not start with the it's corn stuff
because it will get stuck in my head
forever me and my friends already say
it's cone all the time
when I tried it with butter everything
changed it's already in my head what did
you all do to me I already have to go
work and now I'm just gonna be singing
It's cone the entire freaking night
big lump of knobs
yes I kind of agree with you Jonathan
Marvel marketed the cameos so much
should should really just keep people
watching you know like
I
there was barely to me there's barely a
like a story holding it together it was
very much like a sitcom each episode was
kind of its own thing but I've made my
case about this before
even in other sitcoms like there's
always some driving force to a story of
some sort I use the Big Bang Theory as
an example like a lot of the times it's
relationships like Leonard and Penny the
will they won't they Bernadette and
Howard and I get it's not the same show
obviously but uh to me it was just the
lack of like a true main villain kind of
killed it for me and then I would have
actually really liked it if it was more
of a lawyer show I would have been
perfectly fine if like each episode like
the villain was who she was going up
against in court I would have been so
fine with that I would have been
perfectly fine for that
oh nice my friends are going to Camp
Wendy
um
she just came to actually get the key to
my place in LA today
they did kind of make
I lost the comment Richard jmv it was a
failure series that made fun of itself
it did it was very aware it was very
self-aware
I I did not like the writing for the
show
for for those asking
um
yes they confirmed
um
they confirmed in this that uh Hulk I'm
so used to saying She-Hulk at this point
um Hulk is getting his own movie
She-Hulk either Jennifer Walther said
when they were talking about the Hulk
she was like nah save it for the movie
and then at one point in time
Kevin said big screen and she's like me
and he was like no or something whatever
whatever that line was so they basically
confirmed Hulk is getting the movie
Shield was not I mean She-Hulk just got
a series
foreign
[Music]
yeah I could see how people are like
this was a Miss for people it was missed
for me
um there was many enjoyable moments in
the series don't get me wrong it wasn't
just total crap for me but it's like a c
minus for me like um
I you know what I
I'm actually really disappointed because
I really like She-Hulk as a character
there are some things that like
they stuck true to that I really enjoyed
like she's like a party animal in the
comics and like she sleeps around in the
comics so they they kind of stuck true
to that a little bit
um
I I just I I can't
stop going back to they marketed this
wrong
they just marketed the show wrong the
expectations were cameos and Hulk
smashing
I did like her line about
Matt Murdock like how she smashed for
Matt Murdock
all right let's go back to this uh
the poll says 52 enjoyed the finale
the rest in it and let's do another one
did uh here hold on let's do this great
She Hulk as a series
we're gonna do
we're gonna do
uh option we're gonna do
10 98 765 boom there you go do that
go go go go go check go
since
what are we thinking uh oh wow 45 saying
five or below oof we'll give it some
time only
150 votes in it so far
foreign
imagine if she hooks up with a different
guy at the end of each episode Jeff
likes K-pop that's that's honestly what
I thought was gonna happen to be
perfectly
honest
I do think
because I've seen a few people talking
about like cameos and stuff
I do think
maybe I don't want to say we've been
conditioned but I also kind of like
think it
I'm like dodging trying to not
officially say something uh because I
don't know how I feel about it I do
think we've been somewhat conditioned to
expect cameos right
um
and they threw cameos in here but like
I think we expected
Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross like you know
something like that the thing which you
know there was a 10th episode that got
cut
maybe that was the thing
pun intended
um
yeah
the Todd thing
because I'm trying to like go back to
like
the villain
I'm trying to you know just view it for
what it was and and because to me it's
like the lack of a True Villain
just kind of like
didn't provide any tension for me
um
and again like I feel like they were I
just feel like they were in the middle
of like hey let's do this cool lawyer
show but like hey let's kind of like do
this other thing
where she's like struggling between Jen
and the Hulk and then hey let's do this
other thing where it's like
She-Hulk smashes and like fighting and
I'm like
like I would have liked it if they just
would have made it like a lawyer show I
would have been really into that I like
a lot of Lori's shows actually
um
I gotta wrap my head around this but I
I feel like it could have been much
better I feel like the writing for Miss
Marvel
and She-Hulk was up par
and like
maybe I'm just not the target audience
for that
but I'm willing to admit that
I enjoyed Miss Marvel a lot more
I give Miss Marvel like a B minus
ah Jason still put meow meow I don't
know if you've heard
have been to my other channel Cosmic
entertainment because that's what me and
my brothers say on that channel we say
meow meow just kind of as like a pun or
if you're just saying that be funny
either way respect it
um
there you know there were some funny
things that I liked about this finale
but it did it wasn't to me it just
wasn't a satisfying conclusion to
the show
or to the series maybe they did Sue made
a good point earlier on she said they
didn't say She-Hulk will return I hope
she does
I like She-Hulk as a character I like
she-hulk's character in the comics I
I think Jennifer manslani did a great
job wait Jennifer monsalani Tatiana
manslani I just combined her
her character name with her real name
um
Tatiana manslami did a
good job I do I I believe that I think
she did a great job
um
see The Watcher says Miss Marvel was
your least favorite and that's okay
we don't all have to agree
just wasn't for me
to me and just so like for comparison
um
Jeff am I gonna in my K-pop Channel with
another animal sound that's kind of
funny I end it with anyong just bi and
I'll be like a little finger heart
um I am gonna drop that in the chat
again just because there's a lot of new
people if you like K-pop I have a K-pop
Channel that I started I'm not really
advertising that much so there you go
there it is if you like K-pop go for it
and just music in general I'm gonna
do some reactions to music and you know
but
oh back to the whole
I just feel like
I so again I really like She-Hulk as a
character
and I had really excuse me I'm tired and
my voice is going away I had really high
hopes
I had really high hopes for this series
and it kind of Let Me Down
to be perfectly honest it just kind of
Let Me Down
again
if you like the show
please do not let my opinion
change your opinion on it I'm really
happy for all those who like the show
we're all different we all have
different opinions
and when it comes to movies and TV shows
like we should respect each other's
opinions
I get it if you thought the show sucked
I get it if you thought it was great
good
for reference
sorry hold on
good
for reference
my favorite Disney Plus show is Loki
my second favorite Disney Plus show is
one division
to this day what if Still Remains I can
actually say I just
did not like what if at all I give it an
F rating and I know a lot of people
loved it and I'm happy for you I just I
was so bored
and and to me it was it was just because
the lack of connectivity to the MCU just
really didn't have anything to do with
like anything like
and it was cool seeing the scenarios I
would have rather seen them live action
so that's just for reference Loki's my
favorite one Envision my second favorite
um what have sucked to me
um
and then like she was like Hawkeye I
thought were really fun and they were
I I just I feel like I knew what Hawkeye
was gonna be so I just enjoyed the ride
for She-Hulk I thought it was just going
to be way different
yeah
yeah
yeah see some people are like I I hated
what if some people were like I loved
whatever that's fine I'm just trying to
give you like a frame of reference here
right so when I'm like oh I didn't like
She-Hulk
keep in mind I liked Loki in one
division those things are kind of for me
you know
um
and what's funny
I
I like comedies
that's that's the thing the comedy just
didn't
it was hidden it was really hit and miss
for me in this series like
it was really hit and miss some some
jokes I thought were pretty funny and
some I'm just like
no
oh and Moon Knight yeah I really loved
Moon Knight I thought the finale could
have been a bit better
but I really loved midnight as well
midnight probably sits around like
three or four at this point in time I'm
forgetting like like hold on
this point in time I'm like dang there's
so many shows there's so much content
that come out
so it's Loki
probably Loki One Division Moon Knight
Hawkeye
Falcon Winter Soldier Miss Marvel
She-Hulk what if
that's probably where it sits for me
I need to like sit down and like so many
people ask me to do this I just I find
it really hard
to do so so many people have asked me to
rank
phase
four well one we're not done with phase
four but you know do like a rank rank it
so far
and I just find that really hard to do
you know
um
and sometimes I re-watch things and I'm
like this is not as good as I thought it
was or hey this is better than I thought
it was you know
so that's that's it's hard for me to
rank but I need to do that video
I do because I actually I need to sit
down and like I think I need to be it's
fine I'm conflicted because a part of me
excuse me
a part of me thinks
I should know where I stand on each
project and a part of me thinks like you
don't have to have
a favorite
right you know you know just watch what
you want you know I can go back and
watching anytime I want right and enjoy
you know it's like you know
uh
Michael Murdock not a fan of Moon Knight
and again you know it's not for
everybody
I think I might be getting sick because
I'm coughing a lot no I'm feeling
something in my nose and this is not
good
not good well
um
foreign
the next show we get
no it can't be the next show we get
what's the next show we get
is it really the next show we get
it really is
huh so it's a while
we've got a while till
am I wrong
Celestial we did talk about it a few
times I mean I still have this here
oh wait where'd it go I still have this
here on my screen we talked about scar
for a good bit and uh World War Hulk
movie
yeah exactly Mr Anderson it's like uh
you know sometimes I don't feel the need
to rank them right
but at the same time I do think it would
be kind of
cool and beneficial for me to
really look into them and kind of assess
them and think what I and feel figure
out what I think about
um
well I'm sorry I'm looking for a comment
guardians of galaxy holiday special Jeff
likes K-pop to the rescue that is
not a series but yes that is next that
is this
holiday season
um and then secret Invasion spring so
April I don't know
March April
because then it may is Guardians of the
Galaxy
um but anyways what I was getting at was
uh we're gonna do some more live streams
uh hopefully regularly regularly I'm
getting tired hopefully weekly
um and just you know talk about
everything going on in the MCU or just
some cool topics and theories and stuff
um
I do think She-Hulk is gonna pop up more
in the MCU which I'm I'm glad I am glad
I want to see her in other stuff I do I
like the character a lot I like uh
Tatiana manslani
I do
um
yeah armor Wars is a movie now for those
people asking uh
yeah she'll show up again hoax movies
probably gonna come in physics I hope
let's fingers crossed
um
could come phase seven after Secret Wars
but let's hope it comes physics
um
yeah but hey we'll do some more live
streams
um we'll do another one next week and
just talk about a bunch of stuff uh I
love
I love these watch parties I wish they
weren't at 2AM for me
is what it is
but I love these thank you all so much
for showing up
um even if you just popped in and out
thank you
really thank you to everyone who's
chatting it's awesome
um I'm sorry I I obviously can't respond
to every single comment I wish I could
um keep popping in the live streams I'll
try to reply as much as I can thank you
to everybody who super chatted um I
believe I got them all I'm so sorry if I
missed them
every time I was alerted
I made sure to
comment
I got two got Randy got Ryan DJ okay
[Music]
lucky yep cage DJ Leon
Leon are you still in the chat I didn't
know what you meant
Jeff okay sure okay I believe I got all
the super jets
thank you so much for those
[Music]
um
yeah to me it was uh
anyways uh I've said my opinion about
Seahawk I don't need to go into it more
again if you loved it great really happy
for you
um
don't let people's opinion gingers
the writing wasn't exactly for me though
but hey we'll be back with more live
streams and um
I think they're going to be fun I got
some cool ideas for some live streams
having some guests on stuff like that so
stay tuned
um and again thank you to everybody for
joining in the party like I always say
whether you're just watching chatting
Super Chat uh thank you really uh you
guys are awesome you're why I'm able to
do what I do and uh really I'm so
grateful
I really am uh
I love you all so we're not gonna We're
not gonna get mushy don't worry about it
don't worry about it all right so uh I
can't see full check okay oh pole sorry
let's uh
seven percent 10 out of 10 for the
series eight to nine out of ten
ninety percent six to seven thirty eight
percent five or below 35 percent
it's 860 bucks yeah
terrible what I expected uh Mr
Anderson's channel the mod my mod I call
him dmod uh he put that link there be
sure to check it out
um
if you're not subscribed to me subscribe
uh as as you can tell uh if you're new
to the stream I talk about Marvel
shocker right as this is a She-Hulk uh
watch party but anyways all right uh
Alex Wilson goodnight uh same boys and
good night Sue good night celestial
Tozer Lewisberry
good night everybody
uh we'll catch you
we'll catch you next time